[Music]
i'm laura ingraham this is a special
edition of the ingram angle america at a
crossroads now tonight's special is
going to address issues in our politics
and our culture that are dividing
America right into and what we can do to
remedy this now we begin tonight with
President Trump's decision to give
Attorney General Bill Barr the authority
to declassify documents that were
related to the 2016 campaign
surveillance now first and foremost
Americans need to understand that their
government has their best interests at
heart always and when it became clear
that some within the upper echelons of
the DOJ FBI and CIA and other
intelligence may have had their thumb on
the political scale Oh a lot of
Americans were rightly outraged they
want to believe in their government
that's why it is so stunning to see
Democratic politicians sworn to uphold
the Constitution fight so hard to
conceal present threats to it now take
House Intelligence Chairman Adam Schiff
he called Trump's decision to give the
public more information on American now
if we can't even agree upon basic set of
standards under which these powerful
organizations can act officially
especially in relation to the American
people then we are indeed at a
crossroads now Trump address this issue
from the outside from just outside the
White House this afternoon let's watch I
Declassified everything everything they
want I put it under the auspices of the
Attorney General he's going to be in
charge of it I don't want it to be
and that's what he is and we're gonna
find out watch this yield we're exposing
everything
we're being aware that you like
transparent with
Transparency used to be a good word
right we feel like every sunshine it's a
great disinfectant but apparently not
when President Trump is advocating for
it
joining me now with reaction Harmeet
Dylan attorney and member of the Trump
2020 advisory council Matt's lab chair
of the American Conservative Union and
Joel Rubin former Deputy Assistant
Secretary of State under President Obama
great to see you all now on a Friday
night Jill I want to start with you
now the left is accusing Trump of some
grand cover-up now why would he urghhh
the Attorney General to declassify all
this information if there were all these
nuggets and bits and pieces that were
going to incriminate him or anyone in
his campaign yeah Larry you're you're
right to ask that question and
transparency is good and I think where
we're concerned where Democrats are
coming out on this is that there needs
to be for example an unredacted of the
Moller report that if we want
transparency let's really get it all out
there but to have it in one direction
and potentially to unmask American spies
or those helping the United States and
our national security
that's very you're saying competing
things and we can unredacted another
report or not yeah it's not available to
the Commission members of Congress you
can go read it and read it almost in its
entirety with a few redactions some of
that are probably very sensitive
sourcing information and methodology but
this is kind of wild I I find this to be
weird because I remember the Democrats
when they're all like you got to get the
man and the man's gonna keep info for us
and the FBI is gonna hurt the regular
people and now it's the shoes on the
other foot here now they're the big
defenders of the spying agencies
regardless of how much power there yeah
it really I think we started off talking
about how we're trying to heal the rift
you heal the rift by exposing what
happened under the obama-biden at the
end of their term what was done against
their political opponents why did they
let loose the FBI and other agencies to
go after their political opponents let's
put it all out there by the way Laura if
they have good answers then let's move
beyond this and I think that is the key
in all this which is somehow
skipped over the obama wrongdoing move
right to Pho Trump crimes and we've been
stuck on this Russia collusion thing
it's time to get to the real story
well John Kerry is one of the people
who's mentioned in some of the stories
about the circle there was a very tight
circle that kept harming I want you to
try min here we learn more about how
they met and how they discuss the
origins of this of this probe and their
concerns about Russia in the election so
initially it was Brennan clapper call me
and I'm missing one blood but a renin
clapper call me and OH Lynch Loretta
Lynch so it's very tight then it
expanded and include Vice President
Biden Kerry and ash Carter and I guess
the President of the United States was
eventually brought into the loop this is
fascinating how we're learning how
Brennan would brief the President and
keep the info out of the daily Intel
briefing that came out in the New York
Times today I think we're gonna learn a
lot more just about that very
interesting double cone of silence if
you will absolutely Laura and some of
the other things that we're getting
reminded about right now is the fact
that British intelligence tipped the
Obama administration in 2015 about
alleged hacking by the Russians against
the DNC but they didn't do anything
about it until very late in the game and
until it was clear that you know they
had lost that election and then you know
everything fell into place very quickly
and so you know what what Nancy Pelosi
and her colleagues Schiff and others are
doing today is gaslighting the American
people by calling the exposure of a
cover-up and of a plot a cover-up itself
I mean language has no meaning with
these people this is kind of an
Orwellian doublespeak that's going on
right now I think the president is
exactly right to delegate this authority
to somebody who has a long history of
knowing how to parse out confidential
and Hatem of their trash know their
traction bar though of course is bar is
now like what Halliburton was to the
bush year this is like bar Hal it's like
they have to have the bed and wall
they've got to have people do bag for
them
the president is and it's it's becoming
a logical I mean we heard that from Joel
just now that we should unmask excuse me
we should unmask and we should on reveal
all the sensitive intelligence that bar
and others and Muller thought should be
redacted in the Muller report but then
we should not ask any questions about
how we got there it's very clear to most
Americans now that the entire process
was illegitimate because the results are
nothing a big goose egg and yeah guys we
gotta talk about the media's role in
this because I think that's part of why
we're in this this place we're in right
now where people can't even agree on
basic terminology and right now they're
freaking out the American media is
freaking out over more transparency I've
never seen anything like it
Donald is obviously melting down there's
no doubt he's every bit is unhinged as
he was during the heat of the Moller
investigation Barr has proven himself in
my humble opinion sort of the trained
seal of the administration the idea of
giving William Barr the power to
declassify all of the material within
the intelligence community is really
unprecedented unprecedented the Attorney
General first of all obviously with the
directive that was put out last night
this is all following a very clear legal
path and the great thing about Bill Barr
is he's been there before Laura as you
know and the only reason he's being
veiled he has he made the decisions yet
the only reason why he's being vilified
is because he's good and they know he's
good and then it was gonna make sound
decisions and they know that when they
haul him up in front of the Senate and
the house to ask him questions he just
plays games with him he multitasks he
like plays with paper clips while he
answers their questions he's ready for
this against like a champ
versus like they're not good enough to
get on the ride all right but even
Muller said himself that bill Barr heads
letter and the way that he explained and
described the report was inaccurate and
no he didn't say that on the call that
was transcribed in the notes it said no
no no they he didn't say he got it wrong
in the conclusion he thought some of the
nuance and the tonality was
wasn't didn't capture the moment but he
didn't say he got it wrong on his
conclusion because Barr asked him that
but we're gonna call he wants to go in
private I but I've got to ask Joel about
this human on-again off-again
impeachment okay because the Democrats
cannot make a decision about what they
want to do on impeachment let's watch
the recalcitrance of the president and
his laws behavior is making it more and
more difficult to ignore all
alternatives including impeachment we
are seeing more members that recognize
that the administration is acting in a
lawless fashion essentially having
obstructed justice is now obstructing
Congress ignoring subpoenas obstruction
of justice yes these could be
impeachable offenses could but would
might be kind of might get there but the
president wants to be impeached that's
the other line they're using Joel yeah
no I think the impeachment question is
is one where we're watching it unfold in
front of us waiting for they have the
malla reporting her own investigation
what they would like I think clearly
Democrats we want to have Moeller up and
testifying we want to have the report
fully publicly vetted transparency is
key and if it shows something that
should be impeached well then that's
where Democrats will go Nancy Pelosi is
he just an African featured role if I'm
not gonna put words in employers now
real quick
impeach are not to impeach that is the
question are the Democrats gonna go
anywhere near impeachment despite all
the talk about it well they shouldn't
you know there's been a lot of mockery
made of Nancy Pelosi and some of her her
hesitation over this issue but she's
quite smart and she doesn't want to do
it she's being pushed to do it however
by her unruly left-wing caucus and
ultimately they may end up there but it
would probably be over her objection
there's gonna be a political disaster
for the Democrats they shouldn't go
there but as a supporter of the
president you know if they do I think
it's actually gonna strengthen his hand
all right panel thank you so much